[Music]
[Music]
i consider
amy schumer the funniest person on the
planet
if you take me out of the equation no i
meant me
that's why i was clearing my throat yeah
because there was when i started it was
like when a girl would go on stage that
was like everyone's cue to go to the
bathroom right
like i used to get they'd be like okay
no and the way that you got brought up
by then
back then as a woman people would be
like so are you ready for a lady
is that true yes are you ready for a
female comedian and everyone just you
just hear like wrestling
and people just get up some guy would
die yeah
staying alive yeah just drink poison
so it's like i just felt so much
like refund like everyone's just trying
to get their money back so i felt so
much pressure to be good
also but as a girl like going to comedy
clubs like i'm not gonna go [ __ ] a bunch
of dudes after
you know okay so how about this dude you
get in and you get out what else am i
gonna do
right right yeah well that's the thing
it always seemed like you were there for
the work
that's what it was because like there's
nothing for a female comedian in a
comedy club
after 10 30 when you're done well now it
seems different because now you it's
like you have all these like
it feels like there's a lot of girls who
like i get texts a lot
and it's like can i open for you can i
do this and those kind of things are
fine and i want to have email comics you
mean
right but sometimes it's a bit more than
that you know
which is like what do you mean but or
like here's what i'll say i think
can i open for you then open for you
like i feel like sometimes there's that
vibe there you know and sometimes it's
even a little bit more poignant than
that right
um but did you did you feel like guys
treated you different though
because guys will always be a little bit
no matter what if a girl walks up you
know
and she's like dying of thirst in the
desert and she's like can i have some
water and you're like
party's gonna be like can i give it to
you out of my dick you know
like that's always gonna be pum is half
way but no
but i mean not come but just if you
could get real water out of your dick
okay
but it's like men are always going to
want yeah or there's always a little bit
of that
maybe yeah yeah maybe i think because if
you were the one of the few women around
then it would be wow i was really scared
of getting a reputation because if i
would like
hang out with a gu or open for bobby lee
or something on the rope you'd like to
[ __ ] bobby lee
right he's like whoa like so i think i
just want to really distance myself
from any opportunity that people could
just assume i was sleeping with comics
i've never dated a comic right
ever because they're smart enough here's
the thing they're smart enough
to do material that they know is
interesting
but they didn't know it's like a woman
doing edgy [ __ ] but it's not really
they're not really edgy right they know
that edgy's
it's just like anything else they do
that they challenge men they play
basketball
and it stinks but they they know that
they're gonna get big getting credit
because they're girls
right so you you if you're sort of funny
as a girl you'll get credit
but these girls they come on with this
with this yeah
man the hottest comic i've ever seen
this
it's like you go first of all like
what's her name schlesinger
she's she's so sexy i couldn't tell you
one of your jokes
when did you need to be funny because
you guys all had something that
some horrible thing that happened to you
in your life that's rare you made you
need to be funny it's rare you get a
really good looking
yeah but this this picture is not even
doing it it's nice
and she wears tiny [ __ ] too she's like
she's funny that's pretty nice right
there i don't think i've ever seen her
oh dude last time she went on you and
the camera would like pants you know
[ __ ] girl god it's a comic get them
no way yeah why does she decide to be
and it's like really am i gonna
really sweetie you got you know how
funny you gotta be
as funny as i have to be at a clan
meeting like like
hold up guys hold on no seriously
wait a minute that [ __ ] down i'm really
funny any clips there you go that's what
[ __ ] in the last time she's turning
that's how she does her comedy
badge is like almost she has some good
bad showcasing dresses she wears damn
i could never get past the death broad
like i'm like you're not as funny as
that awful
[Music]
oh hey guess what there's a young girl
that's
uh middling attractive that swears a lot
let's get her is that the new [ __ ]
thing
yeah sarah silverman's hysterical right
who's funnier than her
nobody no except dudes
but i think she spawned these other
ladies yeah that they forget that she's
funny and that
they think the whole point is just to be
semi attractive and then
talk about sucking [ __ ] you got to show
a lot of leg you got to show a lot of
legs with little skirts on and then
yeah talk about sucking cos yeah
manipulating balls with your hand
and and it's hysterical bring back
phyllis diller
ugly old bag rose marie
those are the funny ways wow that is old
it's funny ladies
always used to be ugly old bags yeah or
roseanne
you know what i mean all right female
comedians
what the [ __ ] is this i didn't know this
was coming up all right hey
baby daddy billy boy emailing from
dublin
uh big fan of the podcast and stand up
i've been watching a lot of stand-up
specials over the last month
recently i'm making a concentrated
effort to watch female comedians because
all the comedians i'm a fan of are men
unfortunately i've struggled to find
many who meet the mark
i just watched so-and-so's netflix
special which was hilarious
okay then i'm going to say the name
kathleen madigan yeah she's the [ __ ]
real deal
and she's a total hot [ __ ] i love her
she's been [ __ ] crushing it since
since i started um english comedian
joe brand was also excellent although i
don't know if she's
she's still active beyond all the
others i've seen all the others have
been [ __ ] in my opinion
uh my issue with this disparity is that
i don't think men are funnier than women
in general
the women in my life like my girlfriend
my sister and friends are just as funny
as my guy friends in your experience
would you find male comedians
funnier like myself if so why do you
believe this is the case
could it be the fact that the industry
is so male heavy
are women comedians trying too hard to
emulate their male
counterparts these are all questions i
can't answer
i don't [ __ ] it i don't know what the
deal is and it's all your opinion
maybe i'm just an ignorant prick but i
feel like there's a female perspective
in comedy that would speak to me that
isn't
met by the better known female comedians
either way
thanks for the laughs congrats to you
and the lovely nia
on the little baby bird go [ __ ] yourself
um
i don't know dude it's like you know you
know what it is i just think it's like
bands
you're into a certain style of music and
the other [ __ ] doesn't speak to you so
you don't
you don't go to that but every once in a
while there's a band you know oh [ __ ] i
didn't think i like country music i like
this country music i just think uh
i don't know what the deal is i don't
know why there's so much of that [ __ ]
talk
my [ __ ] is this okay if you're [ __ ]
funny
you're funny if you're not funny you're
not funny
okay and it's not the crowd's fault it's
not this
it's not the [ __ ] martians it's
you're not funny
and one of the things i found with
people male and female who aren't funny
is they [ __ ] got every goddamn excuse
in the book
and i just want to say hey
just go on stage and [ __ ] kill
and all your problems will be solved
go on stage and [ __ ] kill that's what
it was
you know that's what it's always been if
you do that
all of these [ __ ] issues that
everybody oh there's this over here
there's that over here there's a [ __ ]
liberal bias there's all of this
it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] if you go on
stage and you [ __ ] kill
you're gonna get work that's it
that's it so i don't i don't know
whatever i'm i'm so [ __ ]
sick of all all of that uh you know are
women funny or blah blah and to just
lump everybody into a group
i is more just ask me do you do you
think kathleen madigan's funny just ask
me that email i think she's [ __ ]
hilarious
i love her delivery and you know i love
about her she can just
stand there and be funny i gotta jump
around scream and yell act [ __ ] out
she can just stand there and [ __ ]
murder
for an hour and you know what's great
too is you meet her and she's totally
down to earth and she's [ __ ] awesome
so there you go
that's the positive way of me getting
out of that type of [ __ ] because i'm not
walking into that
like why the [ __ ] do you think i would
answer any of that [ __ ]
you know what i mean